[Music]
so Martin we missed the Hulk in civil
war that's right but coming back and
thor ragnarok yes but was it nice to
kind of be able to watch the the Marvel
world from a spot without you yeah it
was uh you know we have person I
definitely felt the our absence and
instead yeah Chris Hemsworth is
definitely hurting he's feeling a pain
from that and I can relate to it why
weren't we asked to come join them but
then you two went and did your we're
gonna go do our own thing fine we don't
need any of you guys of know we knew
that that that we'd meet Chris and I had
talked about we've had such a good time
working together on Avengers and the
press and getting to know each other
that we were you know he would always
say mate we got to do something together
and we were actually looking for other
scripts that do together and then when
the idea of Thor 3 came along that
seemed like the perfect opportunity and
we had a great time making that movie oh
well tell me where where everything
stands with Hulk because it was a little
unclear the last we saw Hulk so yeah at
the end
Hulk goes off and and we don't know
where he's going or why he's going or if
he's going on his own volition or looks
tricky that way you don't really know
what he's thinking
why is he so angry all the time but um
he gets he basically ends up in a whole
other dimension and a planet called
Sekar and he lands there it's a it's a
slave planet it
it's kind of a it's a it's a nexus of
all these different wormholes that that
tossed garbage and people and ships and
whatever gets caught into these these
black hole type vortexes and so the
whole planet is made of garbage and
different races and and they've created
kind of a feudal system there that's
basically governed by Jeff Goldblum one
character and he's created the slave
nation that has like a gladiator race on
it as well and and Hulk is taken in as a
slave and and and then brought into the
arena as a gladiator and becomes the
champion of the world of this particular
world so yeah and he's loved he's that
he's adored he's like complex to a whole
different level
totally and and because of the the
physics of this planet
their banner and and Hulk separate out
from each other and so you have a Hulk
that isn't only doesn't exist because
when he's angry but basically is living
he could speak romantic I'm really
trying to wrap my brain or it's all very
comic book II but in the end
Banner Hulk basically is living without
banner for two years and he is he's a
the rock star of this this planet he is
the he is worshipped he is the biggest
celebrity so is it is it cool like a
cool aspect of the character for you
it's amazing cause a because you start
to get to explore Hall yeah outside of
just being angry yeah and we all love
the Hulk because he's always angry and
and and we love that relationship
between him and Banner but uh you know
that there's also something exciting
about beginning to know hulk outside of
that more complex yeah what it would you
know and and he's very funny
he's very childlike of course
he's gone from like a raging
two-year-old to to like a six-year-old
[Laughter]
all these movies he's just getting more
and more mature you know and why they're
2 more decades so be you know a teenager
yes and I and Iowa beat someone else
will be playing him but uh so yeah I got
that I got to really play around and and
and have scenes like whole scenes with
people like Thor and I Thor and Hulk
have these amazing scenes that are you
know they're white tea white tea tea tea
you know Tyco put his improv on tour on
them so they're very funny they're very
quirky they're very character-driven is
there any tension on set with Evans
because you and Hemsworth have had this
buddy situation now you know life goes
on you know we can't sit around and wait
for Chris Evans all of us you know we
have to get on with our lives
you know and it's sad it's bittersweet
but you know he's he has to deal with it
he went off and made his own little you
know little Marvel indie movie with all
the little actors and you know we were
doing and you just sit there and wait it
out like wait for Chris Hemsworth and
all the rest of them to you know come
back around to - Chris and Mark no way
man we're moving on we got our own thing
happy yeah take matters into your own be
at a time let's do this we're doing Thor
3 we don't need you guys well you know
this this particular Avengers is really
taking crossover to a whole new thing
intersectionality I mean guardians of
the gap I mean it is everybody's here 64
characters Marvel how many can you only
have like four lines in the home
with all these other people there
packing a lot like the culmination of
everything it's everything it's the
whole universe yeah how cool has that
been I'm doing all of these different so
cool to see you know Black Panther they
just shot so love those guys you know
getting to know all those people yeah
Chadwick and deny ya deny and and those
are the loons I've worked with you so
far but but that's so cool it's such a
different universe yeah and I mean I
think the core value of this film is
just its diversity yeah and and and that
they're all stronger because of that
diversity you know and I always find I
was thinking these movies is kind of
like modern mythology they sort of
reflect a moment we're in culturally and
you know maybe the ideal of that moment
where we want to be yeah coming out of
that moment and yeah yeah and I really
feel like this you know civil war was
this division and and now it's they all
have to come together to survive and and
it's all this diversity and its really
beautiful culturally diverse and now
you've got more women coming on you can
mark thing barson women I know I know
it's great hopefully they'll roll yeah
and and it's exciting it's cool
yeah and it's left a message about about
women and the strength of women I did
yeah and that's the time we're living
and I know there's 11,000 women running
for office the United States that's not
it's amazing yeah totally
record-breaking yeah and so it's a new
time and these films are reflecting like
you say well we were wired for this yes
that's why it transcends all kinds of
political bonds racial bomb I mean
people love yeah because they're the
they're the stories of gods and monsters
they can and it tells us about ourselves
and it tells us about how we behave in
this new world what's what's right
what's what's moral what you know what
you're doing dad aren't you good enough
did they come to set often I was talking
to Scarlett and she said her daughter
likes to come to set and see her mommy
when she does that she's cute yeah
they're getting to the age now where
they don't like to come as much I do
have one daughter who loves it and she's
just you know she's like brings me my
water and she's 12
okay so she still thinks it's cool he's
still into it okay she loves the whole
it can be overwhelming my son I think
it's overwhelming for him and the little
ones she just gets overwhelmed we just
want to you know yeah be close to me
yeah yeah but Belle is the way music
yeah how do I do this how do I look into
it yes you did leather me you know they
had all the leather works men all these
leatherman on the last mode because it's
all this beautiful leather armoury so we
had all these great Italian craftsmen
with this whole leather department
building all this beautiful leather
armoury and clothing and gorgeous and
she went in there and she was in there
for a week building both of them the
little women and Bella both of them were
building and learning how to do leather
crafting and yeah what are they gonna be
when they grow up I don't know I mean it
could be a so trippy I would be a range
of things could be a range of things
after what you've exposed them to yes
then we're really blessed that way yeah
let's talk about trailer village for
this film I mean it's two parking lots
we get to walk across the parking lot to
get to the other other people and the
other trailer how do you find what what
do you guys do you guys trailer how do
you go to each other's trailers to run
lines yes it like yeah yeah we all end
up usually we congregate somewhere
either it's a group or you know one of
couples or everyone's sort of yeah I'm
gonna have lunch or snacks
and so it's great amazing it's like yeah
it's it's a real friendship it's a
franchise of family everybody's you know
we've been doing this for a long time
now people have a you know you know
families and kids were born during this
and it's it's and we all everyone's
really they're all really great people
yeah this is a kind they're really
humble they're really like it's it's a
it's we're really lucky it's a really
good group of people they are really
decent people and that's you know
there's a lot of gratitude for that
reason among all of you I think
everybody recognizes I think everyone
you know this is this is a it's a great
industry that's people here like there
there are thoughtful people you know and
they and they and they like do good
things with their spare time and their
money and and they we get a lot of we
get a lot of catch a lot of flack from
people but if you look at all the other
industries in the world we're pretty
well behaved we're not we're not
poisoning people we're not stealing from
people we're not ripping people off yeah
and we get and we're the ones are always
getting kicked you know but actually
these are really good and we treat our
people well and we have a small carbon
footprint comparatively any other to
that and someone online joked when they
saw the aerial picture of trailer
village but yours was the one with the
solar panels
I had solar panels I'd better be mine I
love that that might be Scarlett's new
one yeah are you the greenest I try to
be you know I yeah I I try to be I don't
I don't like privately I don't I Drive
the smallest car of everybody I have a
hybrid I asked for an electric car but
there was one available making sure
everybody recycles and yes I put in my
you know I I try not to be too much
about the captain of yeah yeah I don't
want to be a
well you need to get solar panels if
they're not I do and that's a really
great yes you need to get them that's a
very speaking of scarlet and black widow
there's always been this unfulfilled
kind of love or tension between the Hulk
and Black Widow will we ever see that
Coleman its culminate you have to watch
the movie no that doesn't go away yeah
like those things never do yeah
that's either it's required or
unrequited but it never it never goes
away yeah well you'll see you'll see
more of that well I can't wait I mean
you guys are gonna be here for a long
time for a long time and it's all it's
actually these movies sort of uh they
evolve you know we get a script and then
people bring their ideas to it and a
scene might start one way and end a
completely a different way surprising
way yeah so yeah
you